thank you the string of recent fires at
vacant buildings raising a whole lot of
questions especially about what's next
for those buildings after they've been
destroyed by those flames joel mohler is
live right now he's at 7th and ogden in
downtown las vegas where one broke out
earlier this morning joe
yeah brian we've reported on a number of
vacant building fires just within the
past few weeks and even days including
the cabana suites here in downtown this
went up in flames here this morning
there's been a number of buildings like
this you can see crews were out here
tearing this one down we spoke to the
city and they tell us it is up to the
property owners to do something about
these buildings
i am out here getting all of the
graffiti in vegas this is art this is
beautiful for years this vacant building
was a place many enjoyed seeing
max parkstall is from oklahoma he came
here to take pictures of the art in the
area and this building i was like making
sure the location and addresses before i
even hit vegas
soon this building will be leveled the
fact that they're tearing this stuff
down
i understand it but it's sad early
monday a fire broke out now crews here
tell me it's being torn down a number of
fires have broken out at vacant
buildings recently including a second
fire at the crazy horse two on
industrial near sahara just weeks after
a massive fire on the same property the
owner tells me they will be tearing this
down soon as well but other fires are
causing concern too this is not the
first one in this building maybe the
third or maybe even fourth tom smith
says a fire broke out at this empty
motel on fremont and 13th early monday
next door to him fix it
or tear it down the city tells me
property owners must secure vacant
buildings if the building is a public
safety hazard and ownership is
unresponsive the city can pull permits
for demolition and build a property
owner as for this vacant motel right now
it belongs to the tony shea estate and
is for sale if it had been a windy night
these embers could have fallen onto our
roof a nearby fire displaced dozens of
people just over a week ago smith is
concerned this could happen again and be
worse and there goes my home
now back out here live we did reach out
to the fire department as well to ask if
there's been any sort of cause for any
of these fires and they said the
everything is still under investigation
we even asked about the crazy horse too
the multiple fires that happened there
those are under investigation as well
they are also looking into arson as well
reporting live joe molder live local now